[music playing]
- Oh God, my body is trembling.
Oh my God.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
- Look up here, B.
- No, I'm just
looking right here.
- What are you thinking right
now flying through the air?
- I'm just holding on man.
I should probably be grateful
that they're hauling me out
on a wench, instead of making
me pull myself by hand,
but I'm not.
I'm just plain terrified.
- You're almost to me, look.
- I hear your voice.
I can't-- I can't look up.
- You're right here buddy.
Little bit more,
little bit more.
Right there, let's
stop right there.
[bird cawing]
- That wasn't so bad, right?
- Yes it was.
I'm ready to clean, so I can
get the crap out of here.
- You look great, we're going
to get this done, brother.
- OK.
I'm so emotionally attached
to you right now, Mike.
[laughing]
- Mike only gave
me an hour to get
out here, clean the
Skywalk's glass floor,
and get back on land.
Time to put my
training into motion,
even though all I want to do
is get back on solid ground.
- Go up?
- Yeah, start to ascending up.
- There's a lot
of trust involved.
I have to trust Mike, I have
to trust all the equipment
that I'm wearing, I have to
trust the training that I did,
and the hardest thing--
Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa.
I have to trust me.
And somehow push
myself up to the glass.
- Atta boy
- What is that on my foot?
- You're touching me, that's me.
- I Can't get my grip up.
- Use your knee, put up
against that structure.
Nice Go and start cleaning
Bobby whenever you're ready,
time is ticking.
[grunting]
- The one thing we never
practiced, only holding
on to the rope with
one arm, while cleaning
the glass with the other.
I guess I didn't realize
there would be a tourist
here while I was cleaning it.
Hello, folks I'm the
idiot underneath.
Tell everybody you saw
Bobby Bones cleaning
the bottom of the Skywalk.
Tell one, tell all.
- Now the trick is you got to
get all the way to the back.
You got that far
corner to get to.
So we got to get
on those toes, man.
You're relying too much on
the structure and your legs.
Reach out boom, reach out boom.
OK, I need you do that.
It's tricky, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- That a boy, there you go.
Reach out there.
Focus on the glass, don't
worry about what's under you.
[music playing]
- All right, I feel like
I got my first panel done.
- All right, now let's
get that second panel done
and we can get the
hell out of here.
- All right, the key is
to reach right, Mike?
- Key is to reach.
To try to get on
those toes, brother.
Try to use those toes.
Want to try to get that
whole body stretched.
[music playing]
- Doing great, man.
You're doing great.
- One more spot and I'll
have feel like I got it.
- All right, and after
that, brother it's home.
Homeward bound.
[grunting]
- I got it.
Oh my God.
I'm finally done
with the cleaning.
But I'd forgotten about
the scariest part of all,
descending back down the
rope and transferring
to another line.
- Open up that faceplate
and I could see perfectly
what you're doing, man.
[music playing]
Nice and easy start to descend.
Pull the handle, grab the brake
strand like I thought you.
Pull the handle and
you'll start to drop.
That a boy!
- Oh my God.
- Nice and easy.
Start to come down.
Come on down.
- Is there any chance
this thing drops?
Oh my God.
- You just-- no come on.
- Oh my God.
- Come on, yeah.
Just hold it right there.
What I'm gonna do
I'm going to re-hook
you onto your lowering system.
give me some slack.
- I just want to get back
to the land, honestly.
OK, transfer complete.
I'm still alive, but
the wench moves slow
and I know time is running out.
- All right B, see
you on the cliff side.
- I can't freaking wait.
- Bye Bobby.
- Bye.
Oh my God.
- Great freaking job, dude.
- Earth I love you.
I cannot wait to be on you again
and continue our relationship.
- All right, I'm going to come
out and receive you, all right?
[music playing]
- All right, come on in.
- Oh my God,
- All good.
[grunting]
- All right, Bobby!
- I'm not there yet.
- You're there
buddy, you're there.
- Proud of you Bobby.
[sighing]
- So how you feeling?
- Mentally exhausted,
emotionally fatigued,
and my body is whooped.
I see how you guys,
you do this all day
and it's like you really
need some downtime.
I mean, this is the
most grueling thing
I have ever done.
Also the scariest thing
I've ever done ever,
and I've done some pretty
freaking scary stuff.
And I just appreciate you guys,
Mike appreciate you, the team.
I'm very excited
about unhooking myself
and getting on full land.
- Right on Bobby, man.
I'm super proud of you dude.
You overcame your
fears, you got it done.
Looks like a pass, buddy.
Super good job man.
[music playing]